If you open up the GIF preview of your
controller in the Objective C Project,
you'll see the method sharegif.
If you built the app meme,
this code may look very similar to
the code you used to share a meme.
Notice that the GIF is being
sent as an NSData object.
And that the NSData object is
being initialized from the GIF
objects url property.
The ActivityViewController is being
initialized with an array of activity
items which includes just one item,
the animated GIF.
The completion handler is being set so
that if the activity is completed we
return to the RootViewController,
which right now is
the welcome view controller.
The ActivityViewController
is presented modally.
Recreate this functionality in Swift and
then move on to compare your
implementation to the sample code.